[Music]
hi everybody and thank you tejas for the
great introduction
so today in fact i am going to speak
about the ins and outs of core vitals
which are the de facto methods for
measuring performance of the web today
and speaking about performance
imagine that every
speaker's presentation at the conference
loaded like a modern website
um if this was the way that a session
started or let's put it differently if
your website loads like this then by
this time some of you would have been
already out the door
it's a good thing for me that you're a
captive audience and that you can't
leave
but
the reality is that we're seeing more
and more of this on the web today
and you know now the first content is
loaded so finally you have something to
look at
and now
the main content or the largest content
is loaded and finally we can start
so hi everybody my name is dan shapir
like they just said i'm the performance
tech lead at next insurance we are a
unicorn in the insure tech industry
we're looking to revolutionize the way
that insurance is sold to small
businesses in the united states
prior to that i was the performance tech
lead at wix where i worked on improving
the performance of 150 million websites
loaded hosted on the wix platform
as stages mentioned i'm a host and
panelist on the javascript jabber
podcast which if you're interested in
javascript i mean you're here then you
should definitely listen to that we have
something like 10 000 or 20 000
listeners episodes so you know we must
be doing something right
i'm also an invited expert to the w3c
web performance working group so some of
the acronyms that you'll see today are
standards that we're working on in the
context of that group
and most importantly i'm a javascript
aficionado and i'm a big proponent and
lover of the open web i think it's one
of the greatest things ever and again we
wouldn't be here if this if we all
didn't think the same
and of course i'm on twitter make sure
to follow me i usually follow back so
please do
so
peter drucker is considered to be the
father of business management he kind of
invented this whole field and one of the
important things that he said which is
definitely true for business management
but in fact it's true for everything and
in fact particularly true for measuring
performance on the web is that if you
can't measure it you can't improve it
but that immediately raises up another
question
if we want to improve performance what
should we measure
and
this is such an important question
because to a great extent what we
measure determines what we actually
improve because you know that kind of
drives our efforts
and in fact we are spoiled for choice
when we look at the amount of metrics
that are available for measuring
performance on the web like there's a
ton of acronyms here like i just said
and don't worry i won't
you know
check if you remember or know all of
them
but there is actually a problem with
having so many metrics or actually more
than one problem
having too many metrics in fact does
create problems the first problem is
that your website might be fast
according to one metric and then slow
according to another metric so which one
do you trust
which one do you believe which one
better reflects the actual visitors
experience another issue is that with so
many metrics you kind of need to be an
expert in the field to
choose the correct one for every
scenario and even know and understand
what they actually mean because some of
them are actually fairly complicated
and it becomes especially problematic
when you're trying to compare
performance between different websites
usually it says that you want to be
approximately 20 faster than your
competitors if you want to you know get
people to your website thanks to
performance but it's also a problem for
a company like google
because google decided way back in 2010
that they want to look at performance as
a ranking factor google at the end of
the day is serving not you as website
builders but people who are you know on
the web as visitors as users who you
know browse the web and they want to
give these people the best experience
which obviously means directing them at
the best content but also means
directing them at fast websites because
if they direct them at a slow website
their experience will be poor
so google wanted to make performance a
ranking factor in order to select sites
that also have better performance but
that means that they would that they
needed to be able to compare performance
between websites and that as we can saw
is actually a problem
and they in fact specifically mentioned
that performance needs to be relative
and how did they do it
they didn't say it was for a long time
it was kind of a secret it was like one
of the ingredients in the secret sauce
of their search engine
but then they introduced google co-web
vitals because co-web vitals were
introduced at google so we have them to
thank for it
they introduced them almost exactly two
years ago
and what they are are common set of
metrics that can be used across all
websites to measure performance it
doesn't mean that they're ideal for
every website but they can be used with
essentially every website
and an important thing about them is
that they're used using field
information that means information
collected from actual users some people
for some reason assume that google the
search bot uh when it's you know
scans the web also measures performance
that's not the way it works they
actually collect information performance
information from real user sessions
as i said it's now a search ranking
factor replacing the secret one that
google used before
starting on mobile since june 15th and
then february this year on desktop as
well
core web vitals kind of map out the
space of performance on the web
in the in the sense that there are three
main dimensions here there's the loading
speed dimension which is measured using
a metric called largest content for
paint or lcp for short
there's the responsiveness to
interactions when a visitor clicks or
interacts with something which is called
first input delay or fid and there's the
visual stability which looks at how the
screen jumps
and that's called cumulative layout
shift or cls
and where does all this okay so this
data is measured in the field but where
does it actually go so google also
created something called the chrome user
experience report which is a
cloud-hosted database where they
send all this code vital information
that they collect in the field
it's aggregated from not quite but most
chrome sessions uh there are certain
caveats and sometimes they exclude
certain ones it's anonymous of course so
there are no privacy concerns around
this
uh the site needs to have sufficient
traffic in order to be placed into the
chrome user experience report or crux
for short how much is sufficient i don't
know they don't say
all i can say is that in crux you have
approximately 10 million of the top
sessions so that kind of points out at
where the cutoff point is at i'm
guessing something like a few
thousand visitors
per month maybe even a bit more
it does mean however that if your site
is really new you probably won't have
data in crux
another important thing to note about it
is that they use a 28-day rolling
average that means that if you make a
change in your website to improve
performance it won't take effect or you
won't see the impact
for you know a good number of days
potentially weeks
and as i mentioned before it's used by
the google search so they actually go to
that database and use that information
for their ranking signal into the search
engine but
you know really nice of them they also
give us access to this same data so you
have read access obviously you can't
write into that database directly there
are some privacy restrictions but we can
get a lot of
excellent actionable information out of
it
how do we get this information well you
know we can write queries ourselves
using bigquery on on google on the
google cloud but in fact a lot of tools
out there most of them free and to use
and open on the web also get this data
and present it on the screen to us
a common one is page speed insights
which uses google lighthouse on the
inside it's hosted on the web and when i
ran it for our own website here for the
jsconf website
i saw that i got
we got a green score for lcp
and we got a green for a score for cls
and by the way what does green says so i
will show you in a minute but green
means good in this case and this score
is measured at the 75th percentile that
means that 75 of visitors uh the lcp for
them was less or equal to 1.6 seconds
and for 25
it was higher than that you will notice
that there is no data for fid in this
case which means that you visited the
website but you didn't interact enough
with it so if there's not enough
data collected for website we won't see
data for it in this report
there are also a lot of third-party
tools that instead of going to crux
measure the performance directly they
use the same mechanisms usually you you
put them in your website like you would
put in uh
you know google analytics by adding a
script tag and they just start
collecting this data instead of into the
google database into their own database
the advantages being that it's real time
you don't need to wait those 28 days
and it's
also even if you don't have enough
traffic to be in crux these tools will
still show data for you and also it's
for all your sessions at least on
chromium browsers where the apis are
available
not just the ones that have opted in for
crux
so let's start with the first metric
that i mentioned which is the largest
contentful paint this one measures the
rendering time for the largest image or
text block visited visible within the
initial viewport
relative to when the page started
loading so you look at the initials area
of the screen content that's in it only
that counts for lcp you might have a
huge image down you know down the page
below the viewport that doesn't count
and for each metric like this one google
actually pro
specified ranges according to tests and
measures that they conducted with actual
real users actually most of their real
users for the test were google employees
but it is what it is uh so anything
under 2.5 second that's considered good
2.5 to 4 second consider it average or
need improvement and if you're above
four second well then you should get to
work
here's an example of how this is
measured so we start with this is the
cnn website and we start with the first
content that's actually rendered on the
screen that would be the first
contentful paint or fcp but it's also
the first candidate for the lcp with lcp
that's kind of the the trick here is
that what is the last one how do you
know that another one isn't going to
come well you don't and in fact as
content continues to appear we might
have new candidates in each and every
time and i'll talk about when we stop
soon
so first of all that first that was that
candidate
then it was that text here as things
continued to draw it remained the
candidate for the largest contentful
paint because all the other stuff that
was added that area within the viewport
was smaller but then finally when that
main image appeared it was bigger than
that text and it became the largest
content for paint and since that was the
last frame rendered that was the largest
contentful paint that was measured for
that site and the time it would which is
it was measured is the value for the lcp
and the time in this context is relative
to the start time of the page so if
you're familiar with performance dot now
it's the same kind of value
so the first question that we need to
ask ourselves are what elements are
actually even considered for lcp because
it turns out that not everything is even
considered to be content so image
elements are obviously considered also
image image elements within svgs
uh video elements but only if they have
a poster image the video itself does not
count for lcp why well it is what it is
uh url images you know background images
that are specified via css
and also text because obviously text is
content in the text you look at the size
of the containing blo
block level element
there are some content that is not
considered or is not eligible to be
measured as as lcp and that is svg
itself so the image within an svg is
considered but if you like drawing lines
and stuff that is not
and that is interesting because fcp does
take it into account as i mentioned
video without a poster gradient
backgrounds they don't count uh full
viewport images that's an interesting
one if the image covers the entire
viewport it's actually considered to be
background rather than the main content
and is therefore ignored
and
if you make a change to it to something
something becomes smaller or bigger
because let's say a javascript that is
run on the in the on load or something
that change doesn't count
how is the size calculated
images
they take the smaller one between the
intrinsic size initial visible size the
transit size is simply the size of the
image that would be used if it just went
by the the data in the image file itself
and for text it's the smallest bounding
rectangle effectively
css margins stuff like that they don't
count
as i mentioned an important thing with
lcp is when do we actually stop because
you know at any point in time there
might be another bigger
paint that might happen later on unless
again you're almost at the total size of
the screen
well
for a lab data if we do a lab
measurement lcp can also be measured you
know in simulated runs then it's just
arbitrary when that simulation stops
that's when we stop looking for larger
paints but in field data there are
several events that can stop it so
obviously if the page unloads
no more rendering to that page
but also if the page is hidden because
when you hide the page that can you know
mess up the whole measurement and
loading thing so effectively they stop
measuring when the page is hidden and
also interaction that also stops it that
stops it for two reasons one because the
interaction can actually impact what is
rendered and also because if a visitor
interacts with the page it means that
they consider it to be loaded so there's
no more no point in looking for further
things
another useful thing that can be done
with the crux database is that we can
actually
look at data according to technologies
so there's this graph the rea the core
web vitals technology report and by the
way i have links in all the show notes
so if you get the slides afterwards you
can click it and check it out but you
can really look at the performance of
the various technologies and what we can
see is that the situation for lcp is not
that great
if we look across all websites then we
are slightly over 50 percent of websites
that have good lcp
but if we look for example at react
website that means websites that use
react on their homepage then we are only
at what like 35 36
what is it and for wordpress which is
another huge thing on the web uh it's
also not that great which kind of causes
me to think who is the other half but
i don't know
uh
view sites i don't know maybe anyway we
should definitely improve where we are
okay talking about the next metric which
is cumulative layout shift or cls
that's a tricky one
that
measures the layout shift that occurs
any time a visible element changes its
position between rendering frames
cls
measures it in kind of in bursts so
we we accumulate it accord
to some periods of time
but
we then only look at
segments of these measurements and i'll
explain that in a bit and again google
specified ranges for these it's
important to note that cls is not
actually measured in time it's a
unitless number and i'll show in a
second how it's actually computed
so as i said the first thing what does
cls actually measure
so shifts to an element start position
not anything else that's it
as i said unitless score it's a product
or multiplication of the viewport area
impacted and the distance moved and i'll
show an example in a bit
and it's measured for every rendering
frame so for every rendering frame
the chrome engine or the chromium engine
looks at
all the layout shifts that occurred
within that frame and that's the result
for that specific frame
and then it sums these values over time
per session window so here's a real
world example of cls we have the initial
view on the left and then this button
appeared on the right and pushed
everything down or at least the green
part down so the area of the screen of
the viewport impacted is a let's say
it's half it looks up to be about half
so 50
of uh the viewport was impacted and it
was shifted down by well you've got to
believe me it was shifted down by 14
so
uh that's how much it's been moved that
area that was that was shifted down so
the shift score
that that the contribution of that to
the cls would be 0.5 product times
0.14 that is 0.07
and that's the shift that was calculated
for this particular frame
then the frames are summed up according
to session windows
i won't go into the details of this by
the way there's an excellent google
website this graph is from there which
is web.dev and there's a section there
on cls which explains the exact
algorithm but basically it looks to find
the time in within
that
session where there was the greatest
amount of shifts close together so in
this case it would be
it looks to be that in session window 3
or 1 that's the one that had the
greatest amount of shift and that would
be the value that would be used
so again as with lcp where some content
is ignored with cls also some layout
shifts are actually ignored or layout
changes more accurately so if an element
is added or resized that doesn't count
so if you go back to that example the
button itself doesn't count
for the cls because it didn't exist
before and then it was added
so shifts that occur within a
half a second of a user interaction are
also ignored unlike lcp cls does not
stop at user interactions but it ignores
shifts that occur as a result of user
interactions and also very interestingly
and importantly
it ignores shifts
that are not the result of
changes in the start position but
instead are caused by css
transformations so if you use a css
transformation to move an element
or to
then
that doesn't actually get measured at
all you get that one for free
when does it stop so
again with the lab it's effectively
arbitrary when the lab measurement stops
that's when the cls measurement stops so
that's the same as lcp
but as i said with
field data it actually only stops at
unload and that makes it different from
lcp so making the page hidden and then
visible again that doesn't stop it it
resumes measuring also user interaction
as i said
shifts that occur within half a second
are ignored but afterwards it continues
counting it again
and again looking at the cls data that
we see according to technologies we see
that overall the situation is much
better than lcp in fact lcp is the
problematic uh core web vital
measurement at this time if you have a
problem with core vitals it's probably
caused by lcp and that's also the one
that's the most challenging to fix so
with cls we also still have work to do
especially we can see that react is
still underperforming compared to let's
say wordpress or websites in general
but it's a whole lot better than it was
with lcp
the last co-web vital that i want to
mention is the one that deals with
measuring how quickly a website responds
to user interactions a user clicks
something and then you know we want to
respond quickly to that because
otherwise it can really frustrate the
visitor because what is known as reg
clicks you know when you like when you
go to an elevator and you click the
button and nothing happens and you start
clicking like that that's known as rage
clicking so if your website is like that
you know you've got bad user experience
so that measures the time from when a
user first interacts with a page let's
say tap a button until
uh the browser is ready to start
processing that event so for example if
there's associated event handler that's
the time from the actual event until
just when the event handler starts to
run
and again we've got the ranges but you
know what
this metric is actually kind of done
it's not really that
important anymore why because we've won
we can see that for everybody almost
everybody has a perfect score and as you
know from school if everybody in a test
gets a perfect score that means that the
test doesn't really mean that much
anymore so the situation with fid is
that it's still a core vital but google
is actually looking to replace it with
something that's more strict and a
better measurement of interactivity on
the web today because we know that while
fid looks to be almost perfect
interactivity on the web today isn't
really perfect
one the leading candidate at this time
because they're still really trying
things out and discussing it and in
doing all sorts of tests and
measurements is something called
interaction to next paint or imp for
short and it's as i said it's
experimental and it looks at
at one of the pages longest interactions
or close to the pages longer interaction
so it's not just the first one it looks
throughout the entire session
and it measures the time from the
interaction until the resulting paint so
it also includes um that the the actual
run time of the event handler and this
is the reason why the uh
measurements that they allow are
actually longer so if for fid to be good
you need it to be less than a hundred
then for imp you need to you can be as
high as 200 which is actually causing
some debate and concern among some
performance specialists which consider
this to be maybe too lenient
but this so as i mentioned there are
some differences
not just the first
uh the entire time not just until the
event handler runs
and we can see already that even with it
being more lenient
the results are
way worse than they are with fid so
google has actually as part of the
research they have started collecting
data for in from actual sessions in the
field so we can actually start looking
at how they how they appear and we can
see that for react only about 40 percent
of sessions uh get good in in value
which is not really surprising it just
means that we are running a whole lot of
javascript code in the context of our
react applications and that's getting in
the way of our responding sufficiently
quickly to user interactions
so what has been the impact of google
introducing co-web vitals uh we've seen
an increase in performance across across
the board partially it was driven by seo
because once they said it's going to be
a ranking factor seos got all up enough
up in a puff and really started pushing
on us developers to improve performance
but it was also thanks to us being able
to measure and i see that hey our
performance is not where it needs to be
and this is what we need to improve
it also increase the reliance on field
data which i consider to be a great
thing because too many of us measure
performance on our own devices which are
usually the top-end iphone or the latest
and greatest macbook and we have great
internet con connectivity and that's not
the case with many of our users so
relying on field data means that we're
actually feeling what our or
understanding what our users are
experiencing
and as we saw there are many services
out there which you can incorporate into
your product if you want to get the real
user
experience
and it also created a competition so it
created a competition between the
various frameworks so if you look like
it's felt that are you know continuously
uh touting the fact that they are often
creating faster web pages than say react
and also it created a competition
between the various cmss and i used to
work at the cms at wix
so this is the impact that it had on on
us when i was there
when core vitals were introduced only
approximately
eight percent of wix sessions worldwide
were getting good core vitals results
now it's close to 60 percent and that's
uh oh that's actually in the united
states not worldwide but
up from eight percent to 60 percent
within less than two years and that's
why adding a ton of features into the
product and it was
enabled by kova vitals showing us what
we needed to work on what we needed to
improve
so i definitely consider core vitals a
force for good
um it's reversing a trend of ever
worsening performance that we saw prior
to 2020 so we've literally been able to
reverse this trend thanks to core vitals
and this is my message to you you now
have the tools you now have the metrics
you have the capability you have access
to the code
measure
monitor and then start optimizing your
code accordingly
thank you very much
you